[Music]
robotic technologies make our lives and
our jobs easier within our fulfillment
center we have 100 robots and 300
warehouse associates working alongside
those robots Kiva systems developed the
technology behind the bots and this is
the same technology that large global
e-commerce companies are using like
staples Walgreens and Amazon is
deploying in their warehouses as well
when you think of robots you probably
like me think of manufacturing bots so
you're thinking of an auto plant with
you know robots with arms that are
screwing things together the kippah bots
are really just a more simple version of
an automated fork truck they really are
designed to just efficiently pick up
inventory and bring it to our workforce
we try to think of the robots as part of
our team here so one of the ways that we
do that is by letting the associates
interact with the bots by giving them
names we usually try to have a play on
the word bot in there so we have bald
spot parking spot
quiet BOTS actually the spokesperson for
our other 99 BOTS you can follow her on
Twitter at quiet BOTS when you're
working with Kiva BOTS
day in and day out they do tend to take
on human-like qualities you could be
walking through the warehouse floor and
the light blake's and it's like she's
winking at you or we were walking down
the side of the the Kiva floor and it's
like she's following you from quiet
logistics perspective the Kiva robots
are job creators without that technology
we may not have grown as fast as we were
able to grow which is created we're 350
jobs just in this one quiet Center alone
the associates working with the robots
realized that our Kiva BOTS just make
their job easier they're not having to
walk 10 to 12 miles a day looking for
inventory that our customers are
purchasing the robots make us more
efficient they make us more accurate
which ultimately helps the American
economy to compete globally
[Music]